des hôteliers désoeuvrés à barcelone et
un pays où le taux de contamination ne
cessent d'augmenter pour parler de la
situation sanitaire en espagne nous
sommes avec philippe emmanuelli les
médecins français et il exerce dans la
cité catalane
philippe emmanuel y merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
le disait vous exercer à barcelone
comment ça se passe aujourd'hui dans
votre cabinet bonsoir mais écoutez je
vous annonçais il ya environ trois
semaines que on verrait les choses de
façon très claire aujourd'hui
et bien c'est le cas puisque aujourd'hui
donc pas un jour se passe sans que des
contaminations des diagnostics de
contamination comme vide soit fait mais
ce qui est intéressant c'est que
aujourd'hui effectivement de la courbe
des morts elle s'est mise à monter et il
faut revenir maintenant ou 19 mars pour
avoir les mêmes chiffres qu'aujourd'hui
et si on fait un petit peu de
prospection sur les sept jours qui
viennent entre le 19 mars et 7 jours
plus tard lors de la première vague le
nombre de morts avait triplé
donc là on est vraiment un moment clé et
je vous donne rendez vous dans 7 jours
pour voir quelle va être la courbe des
morts
alors je ne dis pas qu'elle va tripler
mais on va avoir un avis très fort
effectivement de la mortalité de cette
deuxième vague
quel est le profil des patients vous
recevez ce sont plutôt des jeunes des
patients avec des symptômes
alors non la plupart des patients qu'on
reçoit ses des patients qui sont
asymptomatiques ou qui ont des symptômes
de type syndrome grippal
on n'a pas vu réapparaître nous pour le
moment dans notre activité des tableaux
grave comme on avait pu revoir lors de
la première vague
donc non c'est vrai que pour le moment
ce qu'on constate surtout c'est que le
taux de positivité des gens contestent
est très important alors la règle et les
restrictions sanitaires prolonger
jusqu'à fin septembre à barcelone
est ce que les premiers effets ce qu'il
y a eu des effets visibles
écoutez pour le moment pas vraiment donc
c'est vrai que non c'est pas quelque
chose qui se note aujourd'hui
alors comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
l'expliquer c'est moins de respect des
gestes barrières dans les rues les gens
font moins attention comment est ce que
vous expliquez cette seconde vague non
si vous voulez la seconde vague
aujourd'hui alors d'abord beaucoup de
gens ont dit qu'il n'y aurait pas de
seconde vague sa cellule vous êtes dans
une seconde vague
d'ailleurs vous l'appelez la seconde rac
vous écoutez moi comme je les dis moi je
me réfère à ce que disent effectivement
à ce que dit l'hôpital universitaire de
barcelone et l'hôpital universitaire de
barcelone german trias mais employer le
terme de seconde vague
donc je crois qu'on peut leur faire
confiance dans leurs analyses
épidémiologiques de la situation alors
maintenant si voulez je pense que on n'a
pas tous les tenants et les aboutissants
sur le plan scientifique de cette de
cette épidémie et notamment et on
commence à en parler on parle
effectivement de saisonnalité du virus
de choses comme ça mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que pour toute épidémie il
ya des cofacteurs est probablement
aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas l'ensemble
des cofacteurs associés au développement
des symptômes de gravité du corps vide
alors on voit ici en france des
campagnes de dépistage massive il ya des
files d'attentes interminables est ce
que c'est le cas également en espagne
alors en espagne vous savez le système
public est divisé en six thèmes prisé et
système public
le système public court après les tests
c'est à dire que vous devez
appeler un numéro gratuit et puis
ensuite une infirmière doit vous
rappeler et ensuite on doit vous
proposer une date de tester ensuite il
faut attendre le résultat du test
aujourd'hui on va dire que dans le
meilleur des cas vous allez entre le
moment où vous allez nécessité un test
et le moment vous allez avoir un
résultat il va s'écouler environ 3 4
jours dans le système privé en revanche
vous pouvez vous faire tester le matin
et avoir un résultat le soir même alors
à madrid la capitale à la situation
semble hors de contrôle est la ville
envisagerait des mesures de confinement
ciblé par quartier est ce que ça va
devenir nécessaire oui les mesures de
confinement par quartier sont annoncées
pour lundi
et oui sans doute c'est nécessaire parce
que madrid aujourd'hui en tête de
peloton dans la rechute de l'épidémie et
c'est vrai que comme le titre est
aujourd'hui el país cette rechute fait
un petit peu la différence entre le co
vite des pauvres locaux vides des riches
parce que une fois encore ce sont les
quartiers les plus pauvres de madrid qui
vont trinquer
et justement comment est ce qu'on
explique que ce soit tout les plus
démunis finalement qui trinquent
davantage par rapport aux quartiers les
plus riches
cette compte à cette constatation il
avait déjà été faite lors de la première
vague on avait vu par exemple sur
barcelone
les quartiers les moins favorisés
effectivement avoir les records en
termes de contamination et de mortalité
et ben écoutez ça s'explique simplement
parce que les conditions d'urbanisme ne
sont pas aussi favorables que celles
qu'on peut voir dans les quartiers
riches je pense merci beaucoup
philippe emmanueli d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin français avec vous exercez en
espagne